من عمان معنا اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك لواء فايز
ما حجم الخطوره التي تحيط بمحطه زبروجا
باعتقادك في ضوء هذا القتال والاستهداف
العسكري لها
الاجابه على هذا السؤال المدير الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه عندما قال الوضع خطر جدا
لماذا لان
القذائف التي اطلقت في هذا اليوم اصابت
بعض المناطق المحيطه
بالمفاعلات النوويه المفاعلات النوويه لم
ل همم لم تصب معدل الاشعاع لا يزال طبيعي
لكن قسم منها فقط في منطقه ما يطلق عليه
اليورانيوم المنضب وهو بعشرات الاطنان ان
لم يكن بمئات لانه لا يوجد رقم دقيق حول
كميه اليورانيوم والمنظم
هو همم يبحث طاقه اشعاعيات تعادل 60% من
اليورانيوم الطبيعي
وتقريبا همم هو همم تعتبر طاقته همم سبعه
واحد واحد بالمئه بالمئه لكن رغم ذلك
يحتوي 204 يورانيو 234
235 لكن هذه النسبه فاصل سبعه واحد واحد
هي ل 235 فيما تقريبا 99.7 ليورانيوم 238
فهذا يمكن ان يسبب كارثه ويعيد العالم الى
كارثه تشير نوبل يعني يبدو السيناريو مكرر
حدث ذلك قبل اشهر عندما جرى القتال بالقرب
من المحطه ذهب رافاييل جروسي بنفسه مدير
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه لتفقد
المحطه وجرها الحديث عن انه سيتم همم نزع
السلاح من حول هذه المحطه لتجنب هذه
المخاطر لماذا فاشله كل هذا السيناريو
وعودنا الى همم هذا الاستهداف لها
لانه حتى هذه اللحظه
كل طرف يتهم الطرف الاخر
هلا المتحدث باسم
الروسيه تتهم والمتحدث العسكري يتهم
اوكرانيا انها وراء عمليات الاستهداف
وتطالب الوكاله الدوليه ان تقوم بواجبات
الحقيقيه ولا تكتفي بالادانه همم البسيمه
الجانب الاوكراني يتهم الجانب الروسي الان
الحقيقه هي الضحيه وهي الغائبه ولهذا
السبب الوكاله الدوليه لا تملك قوه
تنفيذيه من اجل ذلك هي تتقدم بتوصيه
لاخلال منطقه المحيطه من اجل امن الطاقه
لكن يبدو ان هناك استهداف قد تكون
الترجيحات بناءا اعتمدنا على التصريحات
الروسيه التي تدعو للشفافيه قد يكون
استهداف اوكراني انا لا استطيع ان اجزم
بذلك لانه اوكرانيا وتتهم روسيا الان ما
دور الاقمار الصناعيه ما دور الاقمار
الصناعيه المعنيه بم قبض كل حركه على
الجغرافيا الاوكرانيه لانها مغطاه على
مدار 24 ساعه لماذا لا تقدم الدول التي
تملك هذه القدرات هذه القدرات الاستشعاريه
لماذا لا تقدم المعلومه الحقيقيه علما ان
الامر همم يعتبر خطر جدا يوجد سته مفاعلات
تنتج تقريبا
567 ميجا 1000 ميجاوات وبالتالي همم رقم
خيالي هذه هذه المفاعلات تقدم
50% من انتاج الكهرباء المعتمد على
المفاعلات النوويه في اوكرانيا وتنتج خمس
الطاقه الكهربائيه بالمجمل في اوكرانيا
اذا نحن نتحدث عن سته مفاعلات كل مفاعل
شكرا جزيلا لك
العسكري والاستراتي ضعيفه من عمان